first of all i just have to ask for
station casinos as kind of a collective
feeling what does it feel like
to see someone who's finally faces back
on your many properties
after really an unprecedented year and a
half you know the best way to describe
it it feels like home again
we have all our guests here our team
members are here and the resilience of
the city really shown and we are back to
normal now
you guys are going to go back to normal
with a bang with some fireworks in a
couple weeks on the board
celebrating the 45th anniversary of
stations talk about
that plan to really make it a party yeah
so we opened our doors in 1976
uh frankfurt teeter junior did and
changed the industry forever we're
celebrating our 45 years july 1st
we're going to celebrate with some
fireworks so at palace station on july
1st you'll be able to catch some
fireworks and then fourth of july here
in green valley ranch we're going to
have a big firework show for the
community
during the pandemic and that is what
stations did for their employees talk
about
the effort on behalf of station casinos
and its leaders to make sure
employees were taken care of during such
a trying time
you know it was such a time of
uncertainty for all of us but one thing
that was never foreshadowed was our team
members are our family
and they were always priority for frank
lorenzo fertitta and for the company
itself
so we paid our team members all the way
through the closure and then we even
doubled down to increase their reti uh
at a company paid retirement fund and
then to top it all off anybody making
less than a hundred thousand dollars a
year gets free
uh health benefits and free insurance
for them and their family members
we heard from everybody i mean to
provide that kind of comfort in a time
where
everybody doesn't know what's going on i
mean that speaks volumes for just the
company itself and how it works
as people are starting to return you
mentioned it feels like
what are they gravitating towards i'm
curious is it
everything is it more hey i really want
to go to a restaurant or bar
is it a lot of the gaming anything
specific people really seem to have
missed the most
you know it is a little bit of
everything and the one main thing is the
relationships that we have with all our
guests and we continue to build as we
move forward
a lot of people return for one reason
only and it's our team members
themselves
how do you do that how do you keep that
goal for both tourists who like
station properties but also locals who
consider
we make it a very fun safe and clean
environment everybody comes here with
the priority knowing that they are
number one to us
and we'll always build that relationship
and continue on as great as the strip is
when you come here again you really do
feel like you're at home
how challenging was it what was the
biggest challenge last summer with
reopening in a very different way than
now
how did you transcend that challenge in
all your properties it must have been
quite a mountain
um it definitely was but the one thing
about our properties here at station
casinos is we're always known to be the
cleanest and the safest our priority are
always our team members and our guests
so to take that and enhance it just a
little farther to ensure that sense of
comfort with all our guests
as challenging as it was was easy to
accompany like ours and we were able to
do it with immense success
now i'm looking at the now and the
future with business booming and
returning
what does the company foresee with so
many people
clearly ready to see live music again
gamble
go to restaurants and bars and just be
out what does it mean what is the
foresight
you know we're looking to expand more we
have more properties coming in the
future we're going to add more shows
that come down the safety standards are
still in place nothing has changed there
and more importantly we just want
everybody to come and have a great time
at stations
is there a most exciting part for
station casinos
the aspect of when leaders look at this
is there a most exciting part of
finally returning the corner i think the
most exciting part was getting all our
team members back
to work and then providing and opening
our doors for all the guests that not
only come from california but our most
important guests are local guests
well we appreciate you being a part of
our community prize special
we're glad to have you at station
casinos as a part of the community thank
you very much
thank you sir thank you everybody